日本で子供を作る前に知っておきたいこと
信じてもらえないだろうけど
街に化け物が襲ってきた時にそれを自分の
子供に
封印することは不可能だまた子供に
友達と喧嘩させても決して車輪がんを開眼
したりはしない子供が生まれる前に
緑茶のストックを作るんだ確実に必要に
なる子供を作ったら
善の美意識を捨てる必要がある子供を作る
とアーマードコア6をする時間がなくなる
日本で子供を作ると月1万円ももらえる
それがどんどん上がっていく所得税から
引かれている子供の医療費は小学校に入る
まで無料だそれがどんどん上がっていく
消費税から引かれている学校は基本的に
タダだいい学校に入るために必要となる
受講を除いてアキラは3歳児に見せていい
映画ではないらしい女の子が生まれたら
プリキュアの最新シーズンを絶対に見せ
ないこと最新シーズンのグッズが倍以上
高いからストリーミングできるところを
探さずに最初から
宮崎監督のブルーレイセットを買うこと
これだけは信じてくれスティッカーじゃ
なくてシールって言うんだ流しそうめんの
器具を買っても一度しか使わない子供を
作ったらもう一度ひらがなだけで読める
ようになる中高生を育てるには日本は最適
な国だ
闇バイトを無視すればフローリングより
畳の方がかっこいい誰かがおしっこを
漏らすまで子供を作ったらよくも悪くも
あなたはもう一度ポケモンにはまる
念願の屋久島旅行は今行くんだそうですね
その資料は市役所からもらえますそれは
普段から通っている小児科からそれは
保健所から子供が生まれた病院から
あれこれはここでいいんでしたっけ
少々お待ちください
今年からいらないそうですソニー派でも
いずれ
任天堂のゲーム機を買うことになる日本の
リュックは平気で10万円もするお化け
なんてないさ自分の子供に日本語上手って
言われることほど
悔しいことはない